mi sa che cosa bella di te grazie
benvenuti a questo video sono by j
oggi siamo dati gps come avevo promesso
la settimana scorsa facciamo una roba
però diversa abbiamo fatto qualche
settimana fa
quanti in fossimo riesco a fare in dieci
minuti ok volevo provare a fare la
stessa cosa con il rock swing va bene
quindi adesso mi attivo un timer e provo
a fare più rock swing possibili in dieci
minuti non mi ricordo quanti pose volo
fatto in dieci metri pare fossero 20 che
sono tantissimi sono quasi tipo 30
secondi ha imposto il pd tantissimo non
credo che i rock swing ce la farò farne
così tanti perché i ros in sono proprio
alcuni sono proprio lunghi come livelli
quindi non puoi fare molto però ha avuto
un sacco di successo il video vecchio
quindi voglio fare voglio provare a fare
questa cosa adesso vediamo ci sarà un
counter che partirà account free
perfetto vedere questo 10 che rimane
fermo ogni mi piace che mette the
counter diminuisce quindi mettetevi
piace ci siamo ragazzi allora sono
pronto per questa sfida incredibile devo
far partire il canto e scusatemi 32 puro
allora la partenza è buona non è vero
non ho trovato in the rock swing veloce
ad un freezer ok va il velocissimo baia
di oggi deve essere veramente di un
carico che non è l'idea ragazzino xing
sono sembrano facili ma io ve lo dico
sono sempre stati i più difficili quello
che sembrano lo ripeto sempre perché se
ti parte un braccio già non far partire
le braccia usa molto a me era finto è
possibile ma finto la come bellissimo
ok per 30 secondi per fare il primo però
dai veloce quanto quanto dura
velocissimo mamma mia ragazzi ho beccato
un rock swing che veramente poi ci sono
con i corpi quelli che dura un salto non
ci puoi fare niente di paraculo poi se
non riesce a centrare il buco magari ci
mette anche di più prove allora ma
edizione
quanto ci metta a finire sto livello mio
dio dieci minuti se ne vanno solo per
questo parco demonio ai non c'è il
traguardo non si arriva ce l'hai
anch'esso da un ora si è schiantato
superba lavori ha fatto bene sto livello
è fatto da dio
penso sia migliore app su win che io
abbia mai fatto in tutta la mia vita rai
il primo abbia fatto via veloce 80
secondi sono volati nel cesto click to
skype skype skype
vai la partenza del freezer lo quindi
niente male però non sono morto era
quindi ottimo l'importante è non morire
perché se muori perdi un sacco di tempo
ragazzi veramente un sacco però va beh
vi sfido a fare la stessa roba è pro
dovete fare dovete farli in ordine
quindi dovete fare ricerca per nome fa
the rock swing e fa in cerca ordine by
rating quindi dovete fare proprio in
ordine che sono ritrovate con i più
corti e vi battete dovete fare
esattamente i miei provate a far battere
il mio record vaghe difficile attenzione
taiz veloce dai cos'è sta roba
un milione cosa gli iscritti all'albo
cad mi sto guardando però cos'è sta roba
questo sto guardando dai veloce che sono
sette minuti e 40
porca vacca gli alcolizzati fai una
palla va bene la faccio però mamma mi ha
battuto ad alto livello
ok dove entrare il buco ma ma io che
sembra la roba sempre che soffro
perfetto buono buono aggrappati a
straccetta ottimo backflip get like it
is e non aspetta aspetta del no o non
divide sbagliano tv che sbaglio limiti
sbaglio ok teoricamente giusto è
perfetto fammi cedere farmi scendere
vasta quanto dura da 65 a stato hanno
fatto i due solo basta a quanto tempo
per un rock swing dura una vita c'è
veramente ne sto facendo ci mette
veramente un sacco di riso facendo
quelli che durano di più non vale se
fate quelli più corpi e che ci ho messo
poi farne solo due die veloce porca
vacca pensa se morite in una di queste
vedeva niente già perso messe giù skip
schifo dai dai dai dai dai sei minuti e
30 dai valganna cielo tipo degli
anonymous me ne sbatto vai
andiamo avanti rock swing 3 questo è
l'ultimo diga incognito che il ragazzo
che li ha fatti fino adesso devo
centrare il punto madonna ma quanto sono
fatti bene si rock swing bellissimi
[Musica]
secolo meno male
ora che sto facendo la perfect trans
perché praticamente più veloce di così
non potevo essere quindi ottimo per
adesso veramente io sto facendo
velocissimo più veloce di questi sarebbe
impossibile provai che mancano 6 minuti
forza donna di testa perfetto ed et like
this
e peccato che sono così lunghi ragazzi
di bisogno ci mette di farne a manetta
cioè velocisti invece no o alla fine
contiamo però vi giuro dovete battere
facendo sorte by rating sono non vale
ragazzi però sono almeno sono fatti bene
almeno quello fai una palla vabbè fino a
quello riesco a farlo dopo i care no lì
fossero cliccata stato fare aiuto aiuto
usato fare lo applicare non devo
cliccare niente vai sono così di windows
barry ge.ki parte di tetris benissimo
dai veloce quanto tempo schiaccia il
tasto
abbia vinto come ha fatto a farlo
pixellato si è padre che veramente figo
che poi era alto ragazzi sono tutti i
quali livelli adesso lo sto facendo e
dalle tasse cambiano solo le le faccine
non vedo dove devo andare
questa difficile attenzione no tutto no
mica ecco che sarà ma non dovrebbe
succedere ragazzi perché adesso ho perso
un sacco o personal meno un minuto porco
demonio per su minuto ecco se infatti i
primi tre senza morire mi avete battuto
praticamente questo già di già già ho
perso veramente un sacco devo veramente
velocizzare mila porco demoni adesso non
ce la farò mai più a far le cose giuste
lo so ce la faccio a farne due
manca il 4 minuti e bio bio è larga lo
sapete
sapevo che sarebbe stato più difficile
fare questo che li impossible
lo sapevo perché da te sempre così lo so
da sempre cosa che così perché purtroppo
i rock swing
dipende molto dal tipo di livello che
incontri e molto in base al culo non
puoi lanciarvi sul traguardo a te che ti
costa va bene ma io non ci credo nove
ragazzi mi sta dando tutto di sfiga
adesso tutto tutto di sfiga pazzesco tre
minuti e 48 hanno fatti solo tu e devo
farne almeno cinque per come sono fatto
io vorrei farne almeno cinque che
veramente sarebbero tanti rock quindi in
dieci minuti 5 rossini recenti sono
tantissimi secondo me se va bene che
conta che di base e uno dovrebbe farne
tre o quattro cinque sarebbero già buoni
però devo muovermi mancano 3 minuti e 29
non so se ce la faccio ragazzi che non
devi più morire perché se muori non ce
la farei più
mamma mia ragazza è purtroppo è una
sfida difficile ma la sua scelta
difficile lo sapevo che sarebbe stato
difficile quindi ove mio dio veloce e
guarda che per quel salto stupido a
questo lascia l'avrei fatta se non fosse
stato per quello cha va rifatta porco
demonio coi nervi veloce
mica bau bau
ma il cursore del mouse sono cursore del
mouse che i staccati veloce però a mio
dio che sarò ma tifa per chi fa perdere
un sacco di tempo per niente e lo so che
sto perdendo tempo non ve lo ricordate
con la clessidra vai
ok viola roba
devo stare come devo stare dritto ero
molto qua prima 2030 mio dio
da quanto tempo dai veloce perfetto dai
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai magri o
dio era morto qua come faccio a fare il
salto svetta devo aspettare l'ultima poi
tira il mite cammina avanti il loro
slancio madonna garanzia benissimo
dovevo fare così anche per schiaccia
schiaccia veloce ben a langston quelle
minecraft succedendo
cosa è successo bene bene bene
texture play dai dai due minuti devo
farle ancora 21 un minuto ognuno dai
però dove sto andando ragazzi è morto ok
dai un minuto e fredda fu madonna dai
gli attivi a fare velocissimo rock swing
1 marco demonio dove essere veloce un
fulmine poi non morire non ci credo ho
schiacciato
mamma mia non ce la farò mai a farne
cibo ragazzi mai mai mai mai crede in me
stesso ma è veramente difficile è
veramente difficile
[Musica]
mio dio
ok ok va bene va bene va bene va bene va
bene ti prego finisce in fretta però non
durare due anni come tutti i rock swing
che ho fatto fino adesso
don't grave non gravano un grammo non
monet grabow tranquillo non gravo un
minuto cosa in ogni 60 secondi devo
farne due
sì però dai dai ragazzi non ci credo non
entrato 54 c'è manco finisco questo nome
porca put vacca guardava al rock swing
dell'inter ti prego fammi finire può
andare qui ecco fatto veloce che banca
40 secondi veloce lo farne ancora un
altro veloce manca uno deve fare a meno
cinque dai questo velocissimo 30 secondi
ciò non è vero
dovevo andar lì sotto vai vai veloce
staccati 25 secondi staccati 24 tempo
madonna se muoio perso anche se non
muoia mista coperto dai piedi ci siano
né di spararmi 987 ti prego staccati dai
l'ho fatto l'ho fatto l'ho fatto in
tempo prof atitech hanno fatto in tempo
l'ho fatto in tempo fatto in tempo l'ho
fatto in tempo sullo scoccare dello zero
ragazzi
guarda che erano difficili se non fossi
morto in quei due avrei potuto fare
anche sei o sette sei un nome porca
vacca che sfiga è comunque o cinque in
dieci minuti li ho fatti
l'obiettivo incredibile ragazzi spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto vi piace
insistito perché sono gli unici che
faccio completamente quasi completamente
uncut quindi lasciare un commento mi
piace scritte dal canale se ci provate
scrivete mandatemi un target di sinistra
magari li vedo noi ci chiamano prossimo
episodio proverò a fare il top livelli
della classifica generale perché
prossimo episodio se non erano il
160esimo ni dieci episodi
scegliamo sull'episodio e scrive anche
noi lasciato mi piace schiacciate la
campanellina maledetta che quella sera
un sacco e noi come sempre ci vediamo a
un prossimo video belli miei ragazzi
[Musica]